MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Claudio and this is Alain.
We're two engineers in the
Google Drive Developer
Relations Team.
Today, we're going to talk
about an application that
integrates with Drive and that
is available in the Chrome Web
Store, that allows you to do
image editing on the cloud.
We're actually going to show you
two separate applications
from the same producer.
The two applications
are called Pixlr
Editor and Pixlr Express.
As you can easily imagine, Pixlr
Editor is more powerful.
Pixlr Express can be
used to do quick
editing to your images.
But let's see how they work.
Let's move to the screen.
I just downloaded important
wallpaper for my computer from
freewallpapersweb.com.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Everybody
needs a wallpaper.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah,
everybody needs a wallpaper.
So let's see, I have this
beautiful image on my Google
Drive account.
This is of course
work related.
And I need to do some editing.
So I just clicked on File and
it opened into Google Drive
default viewer.
But I previously installed
this application
called Pixlr Editor.
So instead of opening the
application from here, I can
do Open With and select
Pixlr Editor.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: You can do it
from here, or we can do it
back from the Google
Drive web URI.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Exactly.
And of course, Drive, Filter, to
list some applications that
can open that file.
So if you have many applications
installed, but
some of them open text files,
some of them open images, and
some of them can open other
kinds of files.
Of course, when you right click
on an image, you will
only see the applications that
can actually open images, and
Pixlr Editor and Pixlr Express
are two of those.
So let's start with Pixlr
Editor, which
is very, very powerful.
So when we click on a file,
the image gets loaded into
this web interface.
As you can see, we have a
lot of features here.
So some easy ones.
You can, obviously, resize
images, you can add some
editing, you can make this image
worse by drawing on it.
Want to try something?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: What
to draw something?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: What
do you want to draw?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Let's
see, I don't know.
The sun.
Can you draw--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: A sun.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Oh, a black sun.
That's really creepy.
OK, so Alain is definitely
really--
what is that?
OK, OK, that's going to be my
wallpaper for the future.
Thank you, Alain.
So as you can see, you have
a lot of features here.
So you have a number of
filters you can apply.
You have a lot of layers
you can create.
You can resize the image.
You can make it bigger.
You can draw on it.
You can add text.
You have gradients.
What is it you're going
to try now?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
You can select--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Oh,
use Magic Wand.
Oh, great.
I see you're very
good at that.
What else can you do?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Select
this thing.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
OK, now what?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
I don't know.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK, well
you're definitely very good.
So I mean there are actually
people who can do something
with graphic applications.
Alain is not one of those.
And he's randomly pressing
buttons and--
what is that now?
A filter.
You're applying a filter.
Why are you're doing that?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Just
trying to do that.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK,
just trying that.
OK, let's say you made this
image better, and you did that
by adding a smile.
Now, we want to save
that to Drive.
Can we go back to real stuff?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
All right, sure.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK,
let's say you want to
save back to Drive.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So you go
to Find, Save, and then you
have the option to
save to Drive.
So we can save on the same
image or make a copy.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK, and
then you see this same
application, Pixlr Editor, can
save to a number of different
online services.
Of course, you can export it
to your local computer.
So you can have these jpeg
files saved to your local
computer, and use
it from there.
But if you want to save
it to Drive--
you want to save to Picasa,
Flickr, and other social
destinations--
you can do all of
that from here.
So you save it.
And one thing we notice, because
we're going to focus
more on, of course, on the Drive
indication, is that, as
a default, you're saving
it as a copy.
And of course you can
set the quality.
What is the difference in saving
as a copy or saying as
a new file?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: In Drive,
as opposed to an online
[? circumstance, ?]
we can have many files with
the same file name.
So if you save it is
a copy, you have
two files named kittens.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I see.
So let's see what happens.
Let's save it as a copy, and
then when that is done, we go
back to Drive and see
what we have there.
And what we're expecting is to
see two different images, one
with a nice smile
and one without.
And so, let's see, let's
try to open one.
I see we have two.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: First one.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And this is
the original one, and this is
actually good.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
And this one.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK,
you also set a very
low quality, I see.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Obviously,
Pixlr can do
much better than this.
You can select the quality you
want, and I think you made a
very bad choice.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: No, I used
the pixelate feature, so I
tried to do a [? [INAUDIBLE]. ?]
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I see, you
are very good at that.
OK, so this is Pixlr Editor, and
there are some things we
noticed that can be improved and
integration between Pixlr
Editor and Google Drive.
So what we've seen
so far is great.
Of course, you can also create
a new image from scratch from
Google Drive by clicking on
Create, More, and then you see
the list of applications we can
create a file, including
Pixlr Editor.
So when we start from there,
you can create a new image,
you can open an image from
your computer, and so on.
Let's say we create a new one.
OK, you gave a name, and you
can select a size for the
image, and then you can express
your creativity now.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: All right,
let's draw another smiley.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
That's the best thing
you can do, right?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
This is beautiful.
Let's save it to Drive, because
we want to store it
for future generations.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Save to Drive.
There we go.
Extension jpeg, png.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK, so you
have different extensions, you
can save to different formats.
OK.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: The good
thing is that it let's you
know the approximate file size
of the resulting image, so
[INAUDIBLE]
printing out of quota, you
know before saving.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Oh, perfect.
And of course we--
I mean, as image editors--
know with some files formats
you can select a quality so
that you can make the file be
bigger or smaller, but you
have better or worse quality.
So we've got this file in
Google Drive, right.
So we have a new image.
OK, this is working perfectly.
But there's actually a scenario
we've found that is
not perfect, and we wish Pixlr
is going to fix it.
So when you install an
application from the Chrome
Web Store--
and this is the listing
for Pixlr Editor--
the application is added
to the Chrome New Tab
page, which is this.
In the Chrome New Tab page,
you get a link to all the
applications you have installed,
including those
that integrate with Drive.
So you can start Pixlr Editor
from here, and you start it
just by clicking.
And it seems the same.
It seems like the flow
is exactly the same.
But now you create
a new image.
You can select wherever you
want here, as before.
You can draw something.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: All right.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: This time
it's going to be sad.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: OK, why?
Oh.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Because--
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
We'll see why.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
--we'll see why.
So then you try to save, and you
want to save it to Drive.
However, Drive is not included
in the list of cloud
destinations you can save to.
So Pixlr behaves differently if
you start from Drive or if
you start from the
Chrome Web Store.
This is something that should be
addressed for the best user
experience, as the user should
have the same features
regardless of where
they start from.
This should be very
easy to fix.
I think it's just
a small mistake.
And we will definitely
reach out to Pixlr.
Maybe they're watching
us right now, but
let's fix it guys.
OK.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: One
other thing is
opening files from Pixlr.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK,
another thing.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: You have the
option to open image, open
image via URL, or open image
library [INAUDIBLE]
system.
Unfortunately, Drive is not
one of the options.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah,
that's another
thing they can improve.
First, it's not a bug,
it's not an issue.
But users might want to open
a file directly from Drive.
This can be done by using the
Picker API, which is part of
the Google Drive SDK.
And so they can easily embed the
Picker dialogue in their
application, or they might want
to list files into the
style of which they style.
So you have the two options.
Using the Google provided Picker
is very easy, so you
only need a couple of
lines of JavaScript
code and you get it.
But the [INAUDIBLE] will have
the URI we designed it for.
While if you want to write that,
and style it inside your
application, you can basically
draw that yourself.
You have [? calls ?] to list all
the files on Drive and you
can group them into folders,
and so on.
You could do basically
everything with the API, and
then you can embed
it into here.
So we've got two feature
requests for Pixlr from here.
Use or embed a Picker to open
files directly from Drive.
And make sure that if the user
starts from the Chrome New Tab
page or goes directly to
Pixlr.com, these should be
allowed to save to Drive.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: But besides
that, I would say the
application is awesome.
Even, I mean, OK, not you, but
even average users, like me,
they can do crazy things
with Pixlr.
The application is very good.
And obviously, one of the main
advantages is that you can use
that wherever you are
on the cloud.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
On a Chromebook
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: On a
Chromebook, on whatever
computer you are, just log in
to your account with your
credentials, and you
have Pixlr there.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: You don't
even need a desktop anymore.
You don't even need a hard
drive, as all your files are
stored in the cloud.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah,
that's absolutely true.
So we said that we have two
applications to talk about.
Pixlr Editor is the
advanced one.
It has a lot of features,
really a lot.
So you have so many filters, and
so many things you can do
in Pixlr, that a professional
can use that and do a lot of
very good image editing.
But if you're not a pro, let's
say you're Alain, you might
want to use another
application.
Still by the same company, still
by Pixlr, it is called
Pixlr Express.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Let's open it.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
So we're opening the same
file, aren't we?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Yes, the
original kittens from the web.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Freewallpapersweb.com.
So with this application, you
can see the UI is really
simplified.
You have a limited number
of features.
But still a lot.
But limited compared
to the [? prop ?]
application, that is the one
we just talked about.
And you can easily make changes
to the image, applying
some filters.
You can crop image.
You can resize them.
You can apply some effects.
Let's try one.
Let's see how your creativity
goes now.
You have black and white,
dark kittens.
OK, I think we can do better.
For instance, one of the things
I like, you can add
borders to the image.
OK, this is getting funky.
It's getting better
and better.
Another option is
to add borders.
So you have your photo, and you
want to add a nice frame
around it, so you can
do it from here.
And it's not going to be great
now, because everything is
black and white-ish.
But you have a lot of
very easy to use--
vintage kittens now.
How do we get this application
if you want it?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: From
the Chrome Store.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So it's
exactly the same thing.
So we go to the Chrome Web
Store, and we will find Pixlr
Editor and Pixlr Express.
We sell both.
They have--
as all the applications
on the web store--
they have a lot of reviews.
So then you can read about them
before you install the
application.
Remember, reviews are by other
users like you, so you should
probably trust them and read
them before installing any
application.
We install that from here, and
you can launch it from Google
Drive, but you can also
launch it from here.
What happens if you launch the
application from here?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
Let's try that.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Let's see if it
behaves like Pixlr Editor.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Obviously,
we don't have any pictures
because we just opened the app
from Chrome Web Store.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK,
so we need to browse.
And what we would expect, what
we would like to get, is that
you can open a file
from Drive.
So browse doesn't
let you do that.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: No.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: With browse,
you browse your local
files, which is another
important feature.
So that is not the case.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So
you can open URL.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: You
can open a URL.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: From the
web or use your webcam.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So this is
a feature that Pixlr Editor
doesn't have, so remember these
two applications are
targeted at two different
audiences.
So with this [INAUDIBLE]
application, you can, I'd say,
fire up your webcam, take a
photo, and apply some filters.
So maybe you need to create a
new profile photo, this might
be the best application
for you.
You can do that in 10 seconds.
And then you can add these very
good special effects.
Both applications are installed
into Drive.
So once you install them, you
can right-click on any image
file and open an existing file,
or we can do create, and
then select either of those,
and then start a new image.
What are you trying to do now?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: I'm
saving the image.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK, I want
to see what happens now.
So now we have many copies of
this wallpaper we got from
freewallpapersweb.com,
and this is the
latest version of it.
This is amazing.
It's probably your
masterpiece.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: So from Pixlr
Editor, you can only
save a copy.
From Pixlr Express, you
can only save a copy.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: That's save
and replay, save and replay.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: I
missed that, sorry.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: As you can
see, the UI is simplified
compared to Pixlr Editor.
So instead of having a UI
dialogue for saving, you have
two very specific buttons that
say what they're going to do.
So you have one to save and
replay, because of course you
might want to replay
the existing one.
Or you can save a copy.
And everything you said about
saving a copy for
Pixlr Editor applies.
And of course, you can--
I mean, the next one is to
close it and that's it.
OK let's just go
back to Drive.
And just to remind you before
we wrap up, if you want to
start any of these applications,
and you have no
image files on your computer,
you can do Create, select
More, and you'll find all the
applications we have.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH:
That's correct.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK,
I think we're done.
We're basically done with
Pixlr Editor and Pixlr
Express, two great image
editors that
integrate with Drive.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: Two
feature requests.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, we have
two feature requests for
Pixlr Editor, and I'm pretty
sure they're going to be fixed
soon, because so far these
applications are being
developed and adding new
features very, very, quickly.
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: And feature
request for Pixlr Express
integrates with the Picker API
as well, so we can open an
image from the application
directly.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK, last
thing before we wrap up.
If you are a developer, and you
want to integrate with the
Google Drive SDK and you have
technical questions,
where do you go?
ALAIN VONGSOUVANH: [INAUDIBLE]
under the tag Google dash
Drive dash SDK.
We go through the questions
almost every day, and try to
reply to all of them.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cool.
OK, so see you next time on
Google Developers Live.
Thank you for joining us, and
feel free to reach out to us
for any feedback.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]